je
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo votre rendez-vous avec l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
bonjour emilie manuel au sommaire bonus
stock options parachutes dorés ce sont
les mots de la semaine une opinion
choqué un président qui hésite
une gauche qui ne veut pas laisser
passer le scandale retour sur la cascade
de révélations concernant les primes des
dirigeants par temps de crise
autre polémique qui ne se dégonfle pas
la nomination de françois pérol à la
tête du nouveau groupe caisse
d'epargne-banque populaire
l'ex-secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée entendus à l'assemblée
nationale il se défend de tout conflit
d'intérêts
et puis l'explosion du chômage 81 mille
demandeurs d'emploi en plus inscrits au
pôle emploi en février la hausse et
ininterrompue depuis dix mois et elle
n'encaisse pas encore tous les plans
sociaux qui se multiplient dans toute la
france
et pour commenter cette actualité emilie
notre invité cette semaine et c'est jean
christophe cambadélis bienvenue à vous
député socialiste de paris alors vous
étiez vous êtes sans doute encore l'ami
de dominique strauss kahn nous est
également très bien vu aujourd'hui du
clan aubry du clan de martine aubry
puisque vous êtes dans la nouvelle
direction secrétaire national en charge
des affaires internationales
vous serez même à l'occasion vous est
même à l'occasion de ces futures
élections européennes directeur de
campagne lourde tâche lourde mission
puisqu'on sait que ces élections elles
seront importantes pour le parti puis
vous êtes par ailleurs un habitué des
plateaux de télévision un bon
connaisseur des méandres politique voire
politiciens disent ceux qui ne vous
aiment pas et puisque vous êtes un bon
observateur j'ai envie de vous poser
pour commencer cette émission peut-être
cette première question la période
actuelle pour qui est elle la plus
déprimante pour la majorité pour les
socialistes
je crois que c'est pour nicolas sarkozy
parce que il s'aperçoit que le bon
moment est passé l'étape grâce est
terminé et l'état disgrâce et au maximum
il est contestée dans sa majorité et
surtout contestée dans le pays
contesté dans la rue contesté dans le
tout les aspects de la vie politique
économique j'allais dire même culturelle
il y a comme un processus de rejet du
président de la république et en même
temps chez vous maintenant chez les
socialistes l'impérieuse
nécessité d'accompagner les français qui
souffrent de cette crise est ce que vous
faites suffisamment suffisamment pas
encore il faut pas simplement accompagné
sa ce nous faisons tous les jours nos
présidents de région au président qu'on
sait généraux vont et soutiennent les
français en situation difficile qu'il
faut faire c'est construire une
alternative crédible à nicolas sarkozy
parce que le toute la difficulté de la
situation française
c'est que nous n'avons pas d'alternative
autrement que dans deux ans dans trois
ans donc la situation n'est pas simple
la chaleur et donald l'alternative crise
ça commence à faire longtemps vous avez
une date limite maintenant une date
butoir le jeu on pourra se présenter aux
élections législatives c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de faire comprendre c'est à dire
que la difficulté nos institutions
elle est là c'est à dire que les pas de
possibilité de renverser le gouvernement
à l'assemblée nationale comme dans
d'autres démocraties donc on attend 5
ans et en attendant il n'y a qu'une
seule possibilité c'est la rue fameux
problème démocratique est toujours chez
un intermédiaire qui ne sont pas
décisives mais qui sont à terme la donne
au maximum un changement d'une partie du
gouvernement un changement de
gouvernement mais elles ne donnent pas
lieu à une soupape de de sécurité dans
notre démocratie
allez on commence tout de suite la revue
de cette semaine avec l'actualité de
lundi mobilisation justement région
poitou charentes
oui les semaines se suivent et se
ressemblent lundi c'est au tour du
groupe heuliez troisième constructeur
automobile français d'annoncer que 1000
emplois sont menacés
sauf que le groupe a une alliée de poids
pour plaider sa cause ségolène royal
heuliez est en effet un gros poids de 20
installés dans les deux sèvres ségolène
royal souhaite que la région qu'elle
préside rentrer au plus vite dans le
capital de la société et elle demande à
nicolas sarkozy de revenir sur sa
décision de ne pas faire intervenir vous
savez le fameux fonds d'investissement
spécial crise en écoute bien fonds
d'investissement stratégique met en
place par l'état ce fonds
d'investissement stratégique doit
intervenir ici
et sinon il n'y a aucune explication qui
aujourd'hui justifie que le fonds
stratégique ne sera pas intervenue
pourquoi est ce que nicolas sarkozy ne
veut pas que le fonds d'investissement
et de liesse c'est une affaire politique
bah j'ai l'impression ségolène royal a
parfaitement raison il ya un fond qu'est
fait pour intervenir dans des
entreprises qui sont dans des
difficultés ce qui est le cas de
l'entreprise heuliez et parce que c'est
ségolène royal on n'intervient pas c'est
incompréhensible d'autant plus que le
temps à pester pas expliqués sur gaza
lundi qu'il allait faire quelque chose
qu'il allait aider le bruit mais on va
faire quelque chose on met on en est là
elle était présente mais c'est valable
sur tout enfin je veux dire on va faire
on étudie la possibilité 2 on va y
penser vraiment en ce moment le
président de la république élu de les
problèmes elle gagne des points en ce
moment ségolène royal justement sur ce
genre de terrain la proximité
combativité être aux côtés des gens dans
la crise absolument comme tous les
socialistes comme tous les présidents de
région vous remarquerez 10 pour mag non
mais faut pas prendre les choses comme
ça je crois que les présidents de région
les présidents de conseils généraux mais
les présidents de région sont très
impliqué dans les problèmes de leur
territoire et ils sont là ils ont une
des possibilités d'intervention ils ne
peuvent pas faire tout tout seul il faut
que l'état intervienne mais c'est une
démarche de proximité qui me semble
léger ça qu'agir en tant que président
de région elle prépare aussi le terrain
politique pour baser ce qui sera demain
sa candidature à la présidentielle
je crois que ce sera surtout la
candidature à la présidence de la région
la presse
chalon vient un peu plus tard et je
pense que ce serait bien qu'elle soit
réélu oui comment inciter les
entreprises à embaucher des jeunes autre
préoccupation cela dit martin hirsch
propose la création de cent mille
emplois aidés pour les moins de 25 ans
le coût total pour l'état serait de un
milliard et demi ce n'est pas encore
bouclé ce financement
le plan sera arrêtée définitivement la
mi avril la mesure n'est pas sans
rappeler les emplois jeunes du
gouvernement jospin alain ricci en 1988
on parler de génération mitterrand vingt
ans plus tard on parle de génération
active
cette nouvelle formule est celle de
martin hirsch le haut commissaire à la
jeunesse veut financer la préembauche
deux cent mille jeunes par les
entreprises
coût de l'opération pour l'état un
milliard cinq cent mille euros mais ne
lui parlez pas d'emploi gêne c'est une
proposition dans lequel on fait pas des
contrats aidés classiques pourquoi les
contrats aidés classiques
c'est juste un contrat de très courte
durée avec 19,7 pour cent de chômeurs
chez les 16 25 ans la france a l'un des
taux de chômage les plus élevés d'europe
alors des emplois aidés par l'état
pourquoi pas mais sous certaines
conditions ne pas favoriser l'emploi
dans les secteurs qui sont plutôt les
perdants de la crise premier point
fondamental deuxième loi fondamentale
essayer d'avoir une mesure générale car
nous ne savons pas quels sont les
secteurs qui vont les porteurs de la
création d'emplois donc il faut être
ouvert à tous le gouvernement veut
convaincre les branches qui recrutent le
plus la restauration et le bâtiment
doivent continuer d'embaucher pour
préparer au mieux la reprise on met
artificiellement des moyens pour que
vous puissiez bénéficier d'une main
d'oeuvre pendant la période de crise et
qu'elle puisse être formée de votre côté
il faut vous engagez à bien les prendre
quand vous aurez vos besoins de main
d'oeuvre mais la récession est bien là
alors dans ce contexte les entreprises
peuvent-elles prévoir leurs effectifs
futur savons pas quelles sont les
entreprises quelles sont les activités
telles sont les emplois qu'ils ne vont
pas survivre à la crise et ceux qui au
contraire vont sortir le vainqueur est
retombé par la crise en plus de ce plan
le gouvernement veut créer un fonds de
150 millions d'euros pour l'autonomie
des jeunes
l'entreprise total va y participer
histoire de se racheter une bonne
conduite
allez on passe maintenant à la journée
de mardi est le début d'un feuilleton à
rebondissements les grands patrons et
leurs rémunérations
mardi oui la folle journée des primes
des patrons alors que les dirigeants de
la société générale viennent de renoncer
à leurs stock options sur la pression du
gouvernement
libération révèle que thierry morin le
patron démissionnaire de l'équipementier
automobile valeo va toucher pour son
départ un parachute doré d'un peu plus
de 3 millions d'euros
c'est le tollé au sein de la classe
politique même le medef jusque-là
frileux dans ses critiques demande à
thierry morin de renoncer à son
indemnité flora sauvage après la
controverse sur les stock options des
dirigeants de la société générale le
parachute doré du pdg de valeo suscité
un nouveau tollé
lorsqu'une entreprise met en oeuvre un
plan social d'ampleur
lorsqu elle recourt massivement au
chômage partiel et donc à l'aide de
l'état ses dirigeants ne doit pas
percevoir de bonus ils doivent renoncer
à la part variable de leur rémunération
avec 200 millions d'euros de pertes en
2008 et un plan de départs qui prévoit
1600 suppressions de postes thierry
morin le patron de valeo a démissionné
avec un chèque de 3,2 millions d'euros
d'indemnités à la clé pour la première
fois la patronne du medef est monté au
créneau dans une déclaration solennelle
où nous demandons à monsieur morin de
renoncer immédiatement aux indemnités
auxquelles il prétend après le patronat
le gouvernement serre la vis pas
question de laisser faire le patron de
valeo
l'état est aujourd'hui à travers la
caisse des dépôts et le fonds de
modernisation des équipementiers présent
au capital de valeo à hauteur de 8%
il n'est pas au conseil d'administration
encore mais il est membre du capital au
capital et donc il sera à l'assemblée
générale
s'opposera à l'assemblée générale au
versement de ce parachute déjà la gauche
propose une loi pour encadrer les
rémunérations des chefs d'entreprise
pour l'instant le gouvernement ne s'y
oppose pas la polémique enfle dans que
mardi sur ce sujet de la rémunération
des patrons par temps de crise et le
chef de l'état est obligé de se
prononcer il est ce jour-là en
déplacement à saint-quentin dans l'aisne
il renoue avec le terrain les meetings
et c'est vrai que tout le monde ce
jour-là attend qu'ils tranchent faut-il
ou non une loi sur le salaire des
patrons alors ce jour là vous allez
l'entendre
le chef de l'état est certes en verve
mais ils ne répondent pas vraiment à la
question dans les coudes
il ne doit plus y avoir de parachutes
dorés il ne doit plus y avoir de bonus
de distribution d'actions gratuites ou
de stock options dans une entreprise qui
reçoit une aide de l'état ou qui met en
oeuvre un plan social d'ampleur ou qui
recourt massivement au chômage partiel
pourquoi mesdames et messieurs parce que
quand on met en oeuvre un plan social ou
quant au recours au chômage partiel on
recourt aux fonds publics
voilà et au ps on se saisit évidemment
de la réticence de l'elysée à légiférer
sur le sujet pour martine aubry le
discours de 50 ans ce sont des mots rien
que des mots
je vais simplement dire au président de
la république que si son indignation et
sincère au moins sur les hautes
rémunérations
les stock options et les parachutes
dorés et bien qu'ils fassent voté par
les députés ump la proposition de loi
que les socialistes ont déposé et qui
sera discutée le 30 avril prochain
voilà ce que je lui demande ce soir je
lui demande de prendre des mesures pour
relancer la consommation et
l'investissement et je lui demande
puisque la morale et la politique de
doivent faire qu'un de faire voter cette
loi qui mettrait au moins un peu de
justice un peu moins de scandales dans
la façon dont fonctionne aujourd'hui
notre économie voilà et fièrement comme
on le verra un peu plus tard dans la
semaine la ferme a encore rebondi avec
laurence parisot avec le chef de l'état
qui a finalement brandi un projet de
décret quels commentaires vous avez sur
cette semaine effectivement qui s'est
déroulé sur cette problématique là on
imagine que la gauche s'est senti plutôt
à l'aise alors qu'on a senti une
maladroite
oui le président de la république et
tonnes étonnamment hésitant lui
il fonce tout le temps qui est l'énergie
même qui tranchent kick ass qui bouge et
c'est là on n'a personne
rendez vous je sais pas c'est un peu
mystérieux que cette et d'hésitations
gouvernementale je crois que il devrait
se dépêcher il ya l'occasion le 30 avril
nous déposons un projet de loi il suffit
que le gouvernement et le président de
la république dise aujourd'hui c'est pas
suffisant
non c'est passé c'est très simple
d'abord il ya une navette en ce moment
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
sur la fameuse loi par rapport à
l'investissement au niveau des banques
il suffirait d'un amendement à
l'intérieur et ça irait aussi vite qu'un
décret et puis ça serait un peu la
représentation nationale qui ensemble
auraient voté
on n'a pas senti le présent de la
république est gêné il veut pas donner
une victoire symbolique à son opposition
il ne veut pas donner un signe de
régulation un peu trop fort enfin bref
on attend encore une fois sur le choix
du texte du décret c'est politiquement
injuste ou c'est techniquement difficile
quel est le problème avec ce décret
c'est que à partir de là l'ensemble de
la représentation nationale les court
circuiter
or c'est un débat national il donc il
faudrait que tout le monde soit impliqué
dans ce débat nous demandons que cela en
même temps ça permet de cerner ce qu'on
veut de taxer ou interdire ou empêcher
alors effet une loi ça vous pousse à une
espèce de surenchère faut pas non non
non mais écoutez nous on a déposé un
texte donc on voit très bien qu'avec ce
décret on veut ce quiz et les
socialistes de leur texte
or là on nous appelle constamment à
l'union nationale par rapport à la crise
était une belle occasion pour le faire
est-ce que martine aubry a été assez
offensive sur ces sujets ont
l'impression que là vous ouvrez quand
même un boulevard à besancenot
pourquoi on voudrait un baulois
besancenot besancenot se prononce même
pas sur ces questions là il a trop de
problèmes par rapport à ces listes et
par rapport à ses propres militants dans
sa propre formation dont qui aujourd'hui
ne se conjugue pas de l'alternative s'en
occupe rarement mais de l'alternative
politique à la politique de la droite
allez on parlait de nicolas sarkozy à
saint quentin il n'ya pas parler
seulement de la rémunération des patrons
au delà de cette actualité
il s'agissait aussi pour le chef de
l'état de renault je le disais avec le
terrain avec les meetings et de faire
passer un message malgré la crise malgré
les remous de l'actualité le chef de
l'état tient son cap tout de suite le
récit avec hélène langis hardy premier
grand discours depuis le début de
l'année celui de l'explication
nicolas sarkozy a voulu mettre les
choses à plat il a détaillé
méthodiquement toutes les mesures mises
en place depuis le début de la crise
nous avons agi c'était mon devoir
mais mes chers compatriotes je vous en
conjure la sagesse commandent d'attendre
que tout ce qui a été décidé soit mis en
oeuvre qu'on laisse le temps à toutes
ces mesures de produire leurs effets
d'ici là d'autres mesures suivront
d'abord la création d'un poste les
commissaires à la réindustrialisation
nous allons leur donner les pleins
pouvoirs pour mobiliser tous les acteurs
et pour agir
pour les jeunes la population la plus
touchée par le chômage des propositions
seront faites d'ici fin avril
on a six cent mille jeunes en formation
en alternance on va faire davantage
il faut avoir comme objectif de doubler
cela pour mesurer l'efficacité de son
dispositif anti crise nicolas sarkozy
invitera les partenaires sociaux à faire
un bilan avec lui avant l'été le
président affiche toujours autant de
volontarisme politique
pas question de laisser la crise le
freiner ce qui compte c'est la crise
soit l'occasion historique de rattraper
tout le retard et notamment nos retard
en matière d'investissement il faut
profiter de la crise pour investir
massivement dans l'innovation dans
l'éducation dans un nouveau modèle de
croissance
nicolas sarkozy ne reviendra pas sur les
réformes engagées à d'augmentation des
impôts non plus en plus des mesures
économiques nicolas sarkozy est
intervenu sur un de ses terrains favoris
la sécurité avec l'annoncé d'un projet
de loi désormais la seule appartenance à
une bande sera sanctionnée pénalement
d'une peine pouvant aller jusqu'à trois
ans de prison dans la salle 3500
personnes ont écouté le chef de l'état à
saint quentin à l'extérieur un millier
de militants socialistes et de syndicats
ont manifesté vous dirais qu'il est dans
quelle phase de son quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy barile dans une grande
difficulté je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
c'est peut-être le paroxysme de la
contestation
ce qu'il fait et de ce qu'il me fait 10
il est un très bon président de crise
moi j'ai pas l'impression pourquoi il
n'est pas un très bon parce que il peut
se fixer un cap pour le compte est bon
mais il peut se fixer un cap
il est incapable de se dorer d'analyser
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
et 2 d'ajuster c'est à dire qu'il dit on
a décidé ce cap là c'est un plan de
relance riquiqui avec une dix ont une
orientation sur le terrain n'ont pas de
la consommation et mets ça de côté
l'investissement de l'investissement et
donc pas la consommation et il est
incapable de se dire bon bah voilà ça
fait deux mois que c'est fait ça marche
pas en même temps lié à leur tour aux
emplois aidés
la crise pourtant bien que ça marche ou
ça marche pas mais pour l'instant ça ne
marche pas toutes les semaines ils se
prennent en ce moment le creux de la
crise notamment en europe donc on peut
écouter un peu tôt pour dire que ça
marche pas mais c'est clair que ça ne
marche pas et que ça ne marchera pas
parce que quand vous investissez dans
dans l'investissement et pas dans la
consommation vous ne pouvez pas aider
les français et les français souffrent
aujourd'hui il ya des plans sociaux tous
les jours et on leur dit et vient dans
quelques mois dans quelques années ça
ira mieux mais on n'est pas en train de
les aider concrètement qui ces dernières
semaines que nicolas sarkozy était en
train de changer de credo économique je
sens que c'est le fameux d'ailleurs
pragmatisme sarkozyste il recourra
nouveaux emplois aidés
l'interventionnisme étatique est modifié
a été modifié dans sa nature de qu'il
assume quand même s'adapter à ce
contexte ans dans les mots dans les
faits il n'y a rien dans les mots il dit
on va on va on va et puis on ne voit
rien arriver il aurait il aurait fallu
faire une conférence nationale avec tous
les acteurs sociaux avec les partis
politiques d'opposition il aurait fallu
une mobilisation nationale de l'ensemble
du pays
là on a l'impression de quelqu'un qui se
dit je ne sais pas où on va
dans le court terme comme dans le long
terme donc je fais attention pour ne pas
être déstabilisé par le processus même
de la crise donc il est en deçà de la
main on passe à la journée de mercredi
audition à l'assemblée nationale
françois pérol sera-t-il en péril quel
beau jeu de mots il était en effet
l'homme du jour mercredi à l'assemblée
nationale françois pérol nouvel homme
fort de la nouvelle entité à caisse
d'epargne-banque populaire
auditionné par les députés sur la
polémique vous savez qui entoure sa
nomination permet en effet un ancien
proche conseiller du chef de l'état
alors il n'a pas saisi la commission de
déontologie pour vérifier la
compatibilité entre ses anciennes et
nouvelles fonctions tout de suite le
rappel des faits qui est il et puis
surtout les temps forts de cette
audition avec anaïs coup bah tiens c'est
un conseiller de l'ombre qui se retrouve
en pleine lumière
françois pérol énarque de l'inspection
générale des finances est nommé en 2007
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
c'est lui qui est chargé du programme
économique de nicolas sarkozy et c'est
bien ce qu'on lui reproche
fin février 2009 il est nommé à la tête
du groupe caisse d'épargne/banque
populaire problème c'est lui qui aurait
été l'architecte de cette fusion depuis
ses bureaux de l'elysée
mais la loi interdit à tout
fonctionnaire de travailler pour une
entreprise qu'il a surveillée ou
conseillers la polémique enfle nicolas
sarkozy tente de calmer les choses
la commission de déontologie a eu
l'occasion de donner son point de vue ce
point de vue a été communiqué aux deux
banques et il sera rendu public et vous
verrez qu'une fois de plus c'est la
différence entre une polémique et un
problème de problème il n'y en a pas
mais la polémique continuait fait la une
des journaux
la commission de déontologie n'a pas été
saisie c'est son président olivier
fouquet qui a donné son avis personnel
dans une lettre adressée à claude guéant
dans cette lettre olivier fouquet
précise si le secrétaire général adjoint
a exercé les fonctions qui lui étaient
confiées dans les conditions habituelles
d'exercice
la jurisprudence traditionnelle de la
commission lui est applicable
c'est cela que nicolas sarkozy a pris
pour une approbation pour les députés
socialistes qui ont auditionné olivier
fouquet une chose
est clair il s'est fait manipuler par
l'elysée d'où le sentiment d'une d'une
institution qui a subi des pressions
considérables qui elle même envisager sa
propre démission collective
c'est une institution qui vient d'être
écrasé par le pouvoir pour faire passer
un abus de pouvoir
aujourd'hui c'est françois pérol qui
s'est retrouvé devant les députés il a
pris ses nouvelles fonctions le 2 mars
dernier et il se défend non il n'a pas
jugé utile de saisir la commission de
déontologie
je sais que je vais vous décevoir mais
je n'étais pas en charge de l'ensemble
des affaires économiques et financières
de ce pays
j'ai toujours exercé ma fonction en
ayant l'idée que j'étais conseiller que
mon rôle était d'informer le président
de la république que mon rôle était de
lui donner mon avis de lui donner mon
opinion et de l'aider à conduire la
meilleure politique économique et
financière au service du pays la fusion
entre les caisses d'epargne et les
banques populaires
c'est un projet qui est venu des
entreprises
ce n'est pas un projet que j'ai imaginé
ce n'est pas un projet que j'ai organisé
ce n'est pas un projet que j'ai conduit
c'est un projet que les dirigeants de
ces deux groupes ont porté je vous
remercie
à la sortie de l'audition beaucoup de
députés ne sont pas convaincus les
arguments de françois pérol insuffisant
selon comment peut-on imaginer qu'il
était extérieure au dossier il était
comme ça a été dit par beaucoup de
députés il était le le principal acteur
du dossier au nom du président de la
république
l' affaire pérol devrait continuer à
faire du bruit
sa nomination à la tête du nouveau
groupe bancaire fait l'objet d'une
plainte pour prise illégale d'intérêts
le parquet a trois mois pour ouvrir une
enquête ou classer sans suite
voilà et autres mauvaises nouvelles en
fin de semaine pour françois pérol on a
appris que natixis est l'une des
filiales caisse d'epargne-banque
populaire aura versé 70 millions d'euros
de bonus à 3000 salariés pour l'exercice
8 et ce alors même que la banque accuse
pour la même année une perte de 2,8
milliards est annoncé on s'en souvient
un plan social de plus de 2000 personnes
vrai qu'on est là jean christophe
cambadélis dans le cas de figure d'une
banque qui a été aidé par l'état qui va
prêter 2 milliards votre commentaire
quand ça va mal ça va mal et on ne pense
que là du point de vue du président de
la république de monsieur pérol
la situation était paquet enfin il était
clair il avait construit un dossier
auprès du président de la république et
le président de la république lui a dit
tient pas puisque tu connais
parfaitement le dossier tu vas t'en
d'occuper et c'est le fait du prince ça
va jamais pu se dire sous l'ère de la
gauche peut-elle peut-être mais c'est
pas parce que c'était contestable sous
l'ère de la gauche qu'il faut l'accepter
sous l'ère de à moi c'est quand est ce
que c'est le meilleur de xavier bertrand
par exemple ou non mais il voit là parce
que il ya sept cette idée de proximité
je pense celui qui est le plus proche de
moi parce que ça fait parti d'un
quadrillage de l'ensemble des processus
industriels et financiers français bon
bref et puis au fur et à mesure on
s'aperçoit que cette banque comme
d'autres se sont retrouvés dans des
situations difficiles ce qui ne leur a
pas empêché de verser des dividendes à
leurs actionnaires
on est là au coeur de la difficulté du
libéralisme financier que nous ces bonus
pour natixis faudrait les remettre en
cause votre manque évidemment
intéressant dans les contrats d'aidé des
employés offert des cadeaux des traders
y avait tout ça tout ça vient du début
c'est dire qu'au départ quand on a prêté
de dauphin qu'on a prêté qu'on a donné
de l'argent aux banques
on apprenait on n'a fixé aucun aucun
paramètre aucune dans la demande n'a
rien demandé on ne sait même pas mis
dans le conseil d'administration
on leur a donné de l'argent comme ça
sans leur fixe elle une feuille de route
vous auriez nommé qui dans ce cas de
figure dans ce contexte là d'abord je
voudrais profit fonctionnaires qui
veulent et du milieu financier quelqu'un
qui n'avait aucun profit politique je
pense que dans la banque il y avait des
gens qui étaient en capacité de le faire
pourquoi au fbi faut-il mettre un haut
fonctionnaire
pourquoi pas pour les internes en terre
justement 20% de prise de responsabilité
il fallait faire peut-être al'inverse
mettre quelqu'un de
de la direction de la banque à sa
direction et puis rentrer dans le
conseil d'administration
ce qu'il aurait fallu pour une
nationaliser les banques les plus en
difficulté or je pense que si c'était
nécessaire il fallait faire ou mercredi
dans ce climat
c'est une patronne des patrons sous
pression qui vient également devant
l'assemblée nationale pour y être
entendu par deux commissions toujours
contre la loi elle compte elle sur
l'autodiscipline des chefs d'entreprise
événements j'ai redit elle avance avec
le sourire pourtant la patronne des
patrons traversent une période sensible
le gouvernement lui a posé un ultimatum
elle doit faire des propositions sur la
rémunération et vite
alors madame parisot faut-il encadrer
les salaires des patrons j'ai dit que je
n'avais pas le pouvoir
et j'ai dit que je n'avais pas le désir
de l'avoir d'imposer quoi que ce soit
dans ce domaine à tous les chefs
d'entreprise de france plutôt que la loi
elle préfère le code de bonne conduite
qu'elle vient de faire signer aux
entreprises cotées en bourse
problème il n'est pas contraignant et
les habits existe toujours
alors dans ce cas là laurence parisot
préfère s'en remettre à la sanction de
l'opinion publique
quand vous ne respectez pas le code ça
se voit immédiatement
pardon mais un peu comme le le nez au
milieu de la filière donc la première
sanction c'est vraiment celle de
l'opinion publique
l'opinion publique et le code de bonne
conduite mais surtout pour elle c'est la
crise qui se chargera de sanctionner les
patrons récalcitrants au moins cette
année je vais vous dire ce qui va tout
changer c'est pas la loi c'est pas notre
code c'est c'est la crise c'est des
résultats pour les députés de
l'opposition comme pour ceux de la
majorité
tout ça n'est pas assez le rapporteur
pense que seule une nouvelle loi aura
vraiment des effets attendons le 31 mars
puisque le délai n'est pas encore
accomplie mais c'est vrai qu'on s'en
rapproche du crazy stib le mans est la
conclusion va vers ça c'est à dire qu'il
faut quelque chose de légistes fille il
ne reste donc plus que quelques jours à
laurence parisot pour faire connaître
ses propositions
qu'est ce que vous pensez jean
christophe cambadélis du comportement de
laurence parisot dans toute cette
séquence
je crois qu'elle est un peu bringuebalé
par la situation générale et ses
problèmes des rénumérations un petit peu
je sais pas de de naïveté ou de faux
fuyants écoutez c'est très simple un bon
là on sort d'une période où les
dirigeants des entreprises se sont pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux - frais et
ils sont incapables de rétropédaler
c'est un petit nombre d'entre eux parce
que la masse des dirigeants de pme ou
même parfois de grandes humiliations je
ne dis pas je ne dis pas ça mais il y à
cela c'est à dire cet argent fou a fait
que ça a rendu fou toute une série
reprenons l'exemple de la caisse
d'epargne qu'on évoquait tout à leur
joie que le montant des bonus est en
recul de 73% en 2008 par rapport à 2007
c'est donc qu'il ya quand même une
évolution fortement mais non il faut
changer radicalement
mais vous avez quand même définitivement
le principe des bonus et au partant de
la réunion on en temps de crise
comment voulez vous alors que vous allez
avoir 180 mille deux cent mille trois
cent mille cinq cent mille chômeurs de
plus que vous avez une situation où les
hommes et les femmes non non voit pas
d'augmentation de salaire ou dans les
difficultés du point de vue de leur
pouvoir d'achat
là on leur dira mais attendez ils ont
fait quand même des efforts les gars ils
ont décidé de confesser 273% mais
appelez moi ça fait combien tous les
mois ce là c'est plus possible et là où
je partage ce qu'a dit le président de
la république c'est que ce comportement
la mine la cohésion sociale et un jour
on va retrouver tous ces gens dans la
rue et on nous dira il faut quand même
assuré
la cohésion de l'ensemble de notre
pays'' dans notre parti dit il dans les
entreprises il ya des gens qui se
battent et l'idée qu'il part variable du
salaire ça vous pensez que c'est fini
mal an c'est pas le moment c'est pas le
moment nous devons traverser la crise et
tentons on traverse une crise dans une
tempête
ben on réduit la loi alors voilà à l'est
puis décidément mercredi il y à vraiment
des hôtes de marque à l'assemblée
nationale après françois pérol après
laurence parisot c'est au tour de
dominique strauss kahn d'être entendu
par les députés à une semaine du g20
le patron du fmi qui ainsi pu donner sa
vision de la crise il est une crainte
que les états et notamment l'europe ne
fasse pas assez que le milieu de la
finance nos pères pas suffisamment sa
mue on écoute la crainte que j'ai c'est
qu'on n'aille pas assez vite dans
l'assainissement du secteur financier
alors une économie les économies
aujourd'hui ont besoin que le crédit
circule à nouveau que les entreprises
soient à nouveau financées les
particuliers puissent à nouveau acheter
des logements et là les procédures
d'assainissement du système financier
sont encore un peu un peu lente c'est le
côté qu' un peu risqué qui fait que la
reprise n'est pas certaine en 2010 à dsk
qui s'était concocté une vraie semaine
parisienne il était par ailleurs elle
invitait d'une grande émission politique
sur france 2 il à cette occasion à la
une dernière dose qui s'appelle une
belle semaine bien occupé il a été
interrogé notamment sur cette rumeur
persistante qui le donnerai peut-être
partant pour un poste de premier
ministre près de nicolas sarkozy
certains ont trouvé que sa réponse était
un peu molle c'est aussi comme ça que
vous l'avez senti c est une rumeur
persistante qui ont été un peu dur en
est dit mais comment le directeur du fmi
répond durement au président de la
république s'est jamais bien mais
écoutez ça n'a aucun sens quand on est
directeur du fmi
on est dans une crise majeure on espère
d'ici deux ou trois ans pour voir la
surmonter
rentre pas dans des processus
politiciens qui est de devenir premier
ministre de nicolas sarkozy
en vue de quoi pour faire quoi non ça
n'a aucun sens par différence quand on
vient ici en france pour cette semaine
de com explique aux français qu'il ment
la vision sociale démocrate de
l'économie elle est en train de
s'imposer
c'est aussi qu'on a des arrière pensées
politiques par exemple pour l'échéance
présidentielle de 2012
c'est surtout qu'on a une vraie vision
de ce qu'il faut pour l'ensemble de
l'économie mondiale
dominique strauss kahn est un économiste
on le sait il fait partie de cette école
qui est celle des régulateurs
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que la
régulation est une nécessité
il va pas dix ans maintenant j'avais
j'avais raison mais je vais le cacher
non mais vous avez envie qu'eux ils
soient justement à travers cette
expérience qui est en train de lui
donner raison selon vous en situation
d'être là dans le débat politique
national en 2012
de toute façon il le sera sous une forme
ou sous une autre moi ce que je sens
dans les gens j'ai envie c'est le retour
du parti socialiste c'est qu'un parti
socialiste soit capable de d'offrir une
perspective une alternative politique à
une droite qui est en train d'échouer le
fait mieux que le parti socialiste ne se
plie pas que je ne compare pas à lui et
le parti socialiste il ya ce qu'il fait
ce que nous sommes en train de faire sur
lequel vous dit quand il est là à paris
réunit les proches etc
il dit qu'il est dans quelle période de
sa trajectoire politique il nous parle
de la situation internationale et nous
parle pas de la situation politique on
continue avec la politique étrangère et
la stratégie militaire française le
retour de la france dans le commandement
intégré de l'otan
après les députés s'étaient tôt au
sénateur d'en débattre cette semaine
après la décision controversée de
nicolas sarkozy avec une passe d'armes
entre jean pierre chevènement il me
disait affaires étrangères bernard
kouchner
au coeur du débat cette question la
france risque-t-elle de perdre son
indépendance
c'est un contre sens géopolitique que
cette décision que nous demandent en
fait les américains c'est d'être leurs
auxiliaires dans la tâche qu'il
s'assigne de revendre et leur leadership
l'otan est un moyen de solliciter
davantage la contribution militaire de
européen un des opérations de chacun
sait très bien qu elles sont décidées à
washington tout en empêchant que
l'europe se dote d'une défense autonome
or celle ci est la condition d'une
politique étrangère indépendante
la france ne diminue en rien
son indépendance militaire trois
principes fondamentaux continueront de
régir notre participation à l'alliance
d'abord l'indépendance complète de notre
dissuasion nucléaire
deuxièmement la liberté totale
d'appréciation sur la conduite des
opérations et le bien fondé de celle ci
ce qui signifie le rejet de tout
automaticité dans nos engagements
militaires et enfin la liberté de
décision en toute circonstance qui
suppose qu aucune force française ne
soit placé en permanence en temps de
paix sous le commandement de l'otan
allez on passe maintenant à la journée
de jeudi jeudi noir pour l'emploi
quatre-vingt mille nouveaux demandeurs
d'emploi en février c'est la très
mauvaise nouvelle de ce jeudi pour le
dixième mois d'affilée le nombre de
chômeurs augmente il y aura donc
désormais 2,4 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi alors jean christophe
cambadélis soyons honnêtes si la gauche
et est aujourd'hui pouvoir vous auriez
droit grosso modo aux mêmes chiffres
peut-être pas parce que nous aurions pas
nous n'aurions pas eu le paquet fiscal
et donc nous aurions pu faire face dans
un certain nombre de secteurs plus
facilement que le gouvernement qui a un
boulet au pied et qui n'est pas en
capacité aujourd'hui de répondre voulait
dire par exemple que ce sont les heures
supplémentaires détaxées qu'il faudra
aujourd'hui supprimée en particulier et
pas simplement la totalité de cette
politique est une politique qui grèvent
la relance nécessaire en france donc il
faut réajuster dans un certain nombre de
domaines
et puis supprimée au niveau des
bouquetins même vous parlez dominique
strauss kahn qu'une vision des choses
il re situe bien la situation de la
france dans un contexte international où
le chômage frappe tout le monde y
compris l'espagne la grande-bretagne
donc focaliser votre réponse sur le
petit débat franco-français du paquet
fiscal qui dure depuis un an et demi
c'est un petit peu en arrière des enjeux
non pas du tout parce que
il y à une crise qui est international
est une injustice qui est national il ya
la combinaison des deux cette injustice
nationale renforce la situation
difficile international donc nous sommes
obligés je suis désolé de prendre le
petit bout de la lorgnette mais nous
sommes obligés de prendre ceci en compte
est ce que vous savez un petit peu mieux
maintenant comment vous allez là-bas
tirs comment vous allez bâtir les
thématiques de cette campagne des
européennes est effectivement on va ne
parler que du bouclier fiscal par
exemple chez les socialistes
non parce que c'est une campagne
européenne donc il s'agit de contraindre
nicolas sarkozy à changer et réorienter
la construction européenne c'est un seul
et même mouvement que nous allons
exprimer dans cette campagne il s'agit
de changer maintenant aujourd'hui vous
misez sur le fait que ça va être un vote
sanction pour la majorité en place un
vote sanction et un vote actions parce
que l'un ne va pas sans l'autre
il y a une dimension sanction de nicolas
sarkozy par rapport à la politique qu'il
a pu développer une dimension de
sanction de barroso et de la majorité
ppe au parlement européen at il des amis
dans cette situation là et puis pps et
le parti populaire européen c'est les
conservateurs européens qui sont
majoritaires au parlement européen et
puis notre plan de relance au niveau de
la france pour les socialistes
et puis le manifeste européen le
manifesto de 27 partis socialistes qui
se sont mis d'accord sur un certain
nombre de mesures pour relancer et
réorienter la construction européenne
alors jeudi à l'assemblée nationale on
arrive au terme de la première semaine
de ce qu'on appelle le contrôle
parlementaire c'est une conséquence de
la révision de la constitution
les ministres viennent maintenant
s'expliquer devant les députés sur leurs
actions il y a eu laurent wauquiez
valérie pécresse le dernier à s'exprimer
cette semaine c'est michel barnier
interpellé sur la réforme de la pac la
politique agricole commune
pendant que des agriculteurs manifester
à paris contre la redistribution des
aides agricoles jean christophe
cambadélis mal trouvé utile cette
innovation ce changement dans le mode du
travail du parlement les ministres qui
viennent pour des questions un peu
rapide et ciblée
oui voilà c'est des questions un peu
rapide si on n'arrive pas à construire
un débat
dans notre société dans notre société
politique
il faudra avoir du temps il faudrait
avoir la possibilité de pouvoir répondre
au ministre pour aller plus loin pour
pouvoir cibler un certain nombre de
choses la bombasse et quelques
interpellations le ministre on répand et
fils à lui et on sent là je reste trop
cadré c'est pas encore un dialogue lit
oui oui il ya une santé américaine
compétente on voit quand on voit comment
ça se passe dans d'autres démocraties
qu'est ce que c'est qu'on passe et
qu'est ce que ces balises et qu'est ce
que l'on protège les ministres il faut
pas qu'ils puissent être mis en
difficulté
invraisemblable alors qu'aujourd'hui par
le net dans vos émissions les bousculer
tout le monde à l'habitude et barnier
serait bien sûr capable de se défendre
par rapport à un certain nombre de
questions mais surtout on ne veut pas qu
il y un couac à la télévision en même
temps jean marie cavada course à votre
place la semaine dernière disait que
vous ne saviez peut-être pas vous les
députés de gauche et de droite vous
saisir de cette possibilité
d'émancipation sert par exemple faisait
aujourd'hui à possibilité de déposer
davantage de propositions robert vous
n'étiez pas prêt le moment venu alors
peut-être qu'avec vous avez un peu de
mal avec cette prise de liberté vous ne
savez pas l'exploiter suffisamment on
peut dire cela je ne peux pas contredire
un éminent spécialiste de la
communication qui est monsieur cavada
mais ceci étant dire honnêtement c'est
un projet de loi déposé tous les 36 du
mois
c'est une question de temps en temps il
y avait des questions orales qui est
maintenant il ya des questions avec un
public avec un ministre 2 devant nous
c'est les questions à la suite est
maintenant devenu dans rafale tout ça
tout ça je pense que ça ne répond pas à
la nécessité actuelle regarder comment
ça se passe comment les gens adorent les
toc choquant il adore le moment on
discute on va plus loin sur un certain
nombre de sujets on est en retard à
l'assemblée nationale par rapport à ce
que demande l'opinion mais c'est
invraisemblable ils nous traitent de
pingouins on est là dans surnom dans
l'hémicycle a posé une question et avoir
un ministre qui nous répond avec déjà un
truc déjà écrit parce qu tout le monde
sait à peu près la question qui va être
posée moi vous aider sur les chaînes
parlementaires avancé
sur continuer pour cela on va maintenant
passer à la journée de vendredi certains
sont visionnaires et pense déjà à 2000
tous
et mon premier l'une des valeurs
montantes de l'ump mon deuxième était
dans un passé récent le chef de
l'opposition je parlais de jean françois
copé et de françois hollande qui était
ensemble en fin de semaine pour débattre
de la crise à l'initiative de
l'association terra economica françois
hollande qui vous savez s'était mis en
retrait depuis le dernier congrès
socialiste de reims cette fois il est de
retour et hélène langis hardy l'a suivi
de retour sur le devant de la scène
c'est vrai que depuis quelques mois on
n'avait pas vu françois hollande
s'emparer d'un micro en public je pense
nécessaire que je sois moi-même plus
silencieux je n'ai plus de raison de
l'être maintenant après dix ans pour
quatre mois de silence
l'australien de viduité débat argumenté
face à jean-françois copé de tribun pour
décortiquer le plan de relance et
surtout deux hommes qui se connaissent
bien la fois brillant sur la forme
et puis en même temps il faut être
attentif avec lui parce que comme il
arrive avec des arguments il faut remake
des arguments moi j'ai pour habitude de
reconnaître le talent il y en a dans la
salle aussi les sympathisants
reconnaissent ses atouts même s'ils ne
sont pas toujours d'accord sur la suite
des événements je pense qu'il pourrait
faire partie des bons présidentiables
pour 2012
je pense qu'il est excellent dans le
cadre de débat pas qui a été applaudi à
l'instant en revanche en revanche je me
demande s'il sera à même de rassembler
l'ensemble du parti socialiste derrière
lui alors on se risque à poser la
question messieurs la fiche de ce soir
est ce que ça pourrait être celle de
je pense que 2012 jean-françois copé a
déjà fait l'impasse si j'ai bien compris
et vous je ne sais pas la question n'est
pas encore tranchée
mais qu'on se le dise françois hollande
est de retour avec des ambitions à peine
caché les toits la prochaine voilà il
s'agissait bien sûr de terra nova et non
pas de terra economica je m'en excuse
encore vous avez beaucoup ri en
regardant l'optimisme de françois
hollande quand il parle de 2012
optimiste je suis pas sûr gilles parce
qu'il répond en disant je ne sais pas
encore si je ferai comme jean françois
copé c'est à dire si je passerai mon
tour je pense que tout ça c'est trop tôt
on n'est pas là dans intentionnel
tous m'ont dit ça c'est trop tôt et en
même temps tout le monde est déjà dans
cette projection là que ce soit
dominique strauss kahn sans doute en
tout cas ségolène royal ou d'eau surtout
les journalistes y sont dedans mais en
politique aussi s'est bien préparé cinq
ans avant à l'échéance présidentielle
non il listé préparer beaucoup plus en
avant au moins dix ans auparavant
mais le problème c'est la situation
actuelle
vous ne savez pas si l'élection se fera
dans une phase où la situation
économique aura décollé ou ne serons
dans une crise majeure ou si les gens
sont dans la rue ou s'il y aura eu des
chocs majeurs politique c'était on
réfléchit à un casting alors ce qui nous
a alors qu'il nous faudrait un scénar
c'est ça le problème
donc il faut il faut essayer de de voir
ce que pourrait être une orientation
pour la france et non pas qui serait le
plus sympa le meilleur le plus brillant
le cap le plus capable de répondre aux
questions des journalistes
or dans l'actualité cette semaine
nicolas sarkozy bien sûr qui part en
tournée en afrique
brazzaville la république démocratique
du congo le niger 3 étapes en deux jours
un mini périple au cours duquel le
président ne manque pas de rappeler les
nouvelles relations qu'il veut instaurer
avec l'afrique sans toujours convaincre
alain ricci le drapeau de la rupture est
en berne pour son quatrième voyage en
afrique noire nicolas sarkozy n'aura pas
eu la peau de l'afrique de papa
on est un peu dans cette tension entre
le maintien de relations privilégiées
avec des pays francophones qui sont des
ex colonies et la volonté de
normalisation ou de diversification des
relations
il faut dire que les liens sont étroits
entre l'afrique et la france la france
est le premier partenaire économique de
l'afrique
chaque année les entreprises françaises
y réalise 53 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires d'ailleurs le groupe
nucléaire areva vient de signer un
accord sur l'exploitation de mines
d'uranium en république démocratique du
congo la rupture selon le président
sarkozy et est surtout la volonté de
trouver de nouveaux partenaires en
afrique
au delà du pré carré francophone
traditionnelle et la france vise
notamment de nouvelles puissances
africaines qui sont pour la plupart
anglophones c'est le nigeria s'est aussi
l'afrique du sud la france et l'afrique
ce sont aussi des relations militaires
et de stabilisation politique le
président français veut un nouvel élan
de la coopération régionale plus de
projets en commun en matière de
transport et d'énergie pour moins de
conflits en afrique la présence
militaire française est forte quatre
bases militaires avec plus de 2000
hommes et 100 mille militaires déployés
sur 5 zones de guerre c'est un peu un
jeu j'irai d'équilibriste on va dire
pour simplifier entre la realpolitik qui
vise des objectifs on va dire politique
militaire et économique et le
le respect des droits de l'homme
l'offensif chinoise et le retour des
états unis en afrique laisse peu de
marge de manoeuvre à la france surtout
sur le plan démocratique
voilà c'était la fin de semaine
africaine du chef de l'état s'est aussi
à la fin de cette émission car nous
sommes très en retard merci beaucoup je
pense que geof cambadélis et avec
emmanuel on se retrouve bien sûr la
semaine prochaine pour jouer endroit
même heure à la semaine prochaine